Hey,
what's going on?
It's Bill Barth and it's the Monday morning podcast from Monday,
July 30th,
20 1212 years past the year of our Lord.
The year 2000 number that and all the computers were going to crash and everyone
was going to run around with their hair on fire
and what happened?
Nothing.
Oh my God.
It comes in as dry way.
I missed us.
How many fucking times do they going to cry wolf?
How many times are they going to say that everything's going to fucking end and
it never does.
I wanna know.
I want to know.
They call be the big three,
the woo,
but songs in my head today,
I don't know why.
Maybe it's because you don't like yourself bill,
and you're sick of the lies.
Maybe it is.
I don't know what.
All I know is I took my dog out for a walk.
She did a four,
which is number two twice.
First one was solid,
second one started to come out like it was going to be,
and then all of a sudden,
right?
Don't want to wait.
Do I?
Do you know what I do?
I do my best.
I do my best to be irresponsible neighbor.
You know,
I saw three people in my neighborhood just sitting in a car and I just
immediately assumed that they were pieces of shit.
They had tattoos,
they were smoking cigarettes,
they just look like scumbags.
And I was sitting at gone,
well they're kind of sort of white,
so that's not racist is it?
But there are real specific kind of white,
like their nationality.
They were 100% of whatever the fuck they were.
And I'll tell you right now,
I didn't like all right.
And my inner old man was starting to come out like,
it's weird when you buy a house,
you just suddenly become really conservative.
Before when I rented,
I didn't give a shit.
If there was a homeless guy jerking off on the street,
I thought it was funny.
Look at that guy right outside my window.
Who needs cable when that guy's sitting there rubbing one out?
Oh look at a lady running was great.
But once you buy you every fucking little thing,
there's a pot hall down the street.
And you need to be covered.
I did the other day.
That's how old I am.
I called three,
one one for the first time in my life to you.
Hey Man,
can we help you please now what said?
Yeah,
there's that old guy,
you know,
old people,
Bitch,
old people bitch like that.
You already heard the 0.9 times,
you know,
welcome to 301 what can we help you with that there's Pine Hall.
It's still not covered.
I don't know which one you're talking about.
Crazy old man.
Crazy freckle.
The old man bill.
Um,
yeah.
So I'm doing the podcast late today and uh,
you know I am doing it late today cause I recorded one and it wasn't funny and I
have a certain level of quality control and they go get some nourishment and at
the end of the day I'll do this thing.
Whenever the fuck I damn well pleased.
All right,
so I'll you Twitter.
Can you tcs out there?
If you want to keep fucking writing to me and Bitch Moan and complain and just
know this.
I don't give a shit.
You know,
I know why you keep bitching at me because there's this new culture now where
you have to apologize for nothing.
Is that what you're waiting for me to do?
Do you want me to go on,
on Twitter and issue an apology?
I find it offensive that he calls it the Monday morning podcast and when he
records it,
it's his Monday morning and not mine.
I feel it's false.
Go Fuck Yourself.
That's what this week was.
This was a week of watching people that I'm huge fans of having to apologize or
semi apologize or finesse
for nothing.
Absolutely nothing.
Fred Willard,
who doesn't like Fred Willard,
you know,
he allegedly rubbed one out or something,
touched himself in a lewd way.
Lewd,
such a great word,
isn't it?
They'd really just sounds like,
what the fuck it is.
Lewd,
you know,
crude.
Anything.
Food is not good.
Right?
Zune.
Is there another word?
Lewd.
Crude mood.
That mood could be off.
Shut up bill when he's trying to do some fucking Seinfeld bit here.
Why does everything that goes who'd,
um,
yeah,
lewd,
Lewd.
Just sounds like it.
Touching your fucking balls.
Doesn't it a lewd act that you'd like come with that sound effect?
Uron up.
The shush backed is be a charged with two counts of a lewd act.
Right.
And you've got to like act it out as you say it.
No.
Well you wouldn't my court,
um,
in my fantasy court that I have,
yeah,
Fred Willard allegedly touched himself while watching a porno and he has to
fucking issue some sort of state for what?
For,
you know,
first of all,
I don't understand what,
why are you apologizing to me or why are you trying to clear the air with me?
I don't care what you do.
Just make a good movie and I'll go see it.
I don't care what you're doing.
Like,
all right,
if you're out murdering people and touch and kids,
yeah,
I have a problem.
But if you're rubbing one out,
I don't give a fuck.
Is it or is it not a good movie,
Fred Willard?
If it is,
I will go see it regardless of how you empty your balls.
I don't care.
The only reason why I needed to hear him issue a statement would be he should
only issued a statement to the person who owned the meat,
the movie theater,
the guy whose job it is to mop up after the shows and possibly the person that
was sitting in front of,
in front of him.
And that only is if,
when Fred climaxes,
he rises to his feet.
Other than that,
what do you,
why?
I don't need to know about it.
I don't give a fuck.
I don't care what anybody does.
If you're not hurting somebody,
John Travolta is getting a massage.
He goes,
hey,
you want to rub one out there?
Male Massoud and the guy goes,
no I don't.
And then I don't give a shit.
And then what?
I'm not going to see his next movie.
If it's good,
I'm going to go see it.
I don't care what that guy does.
It's none of my business.
And I don't think any of that shit is embarrassing or I don't think there's any
shame,
you know,
it's not our fault.
Our balls fill up and we got to get rid of it.
You know,
and there's a bunch of different ways to do it.
And if you're not hurting anybody,
I don't see what the problem is.
You know,
I don't,
I don't get why,
why you're apologizing me.
You jerked off to allegedly jerked off to a porno.
I mean,
what are you going to do next?
He's always gotta apologize for playing catch with a baseball.
I mean,
that's what,
that's what it's here for me p they make pornos so you jerk off to them.
All right?
If you don't want somebody to jerk off and you fucking allegedly jerk off in
your movie theater,
don't fucking show pornos.
Why don't you show Spiderman?
Okay.
Yeah,
you go,
there you go.
If he was jerking off while watching Spiderman,
about teens,
is Christ Fred,
this kids there,
you know?
And even then,
if he wasn't looking at any of them,
if you just was truly turned on by Spiderman or the the chick who was Dayton
pita plaque,
then that's,
to me,
that's his own fucking issue.
You'll go with me,
Fred.
Well,
it,
I'm going to go see your next movie,
whether I think it looks good or not.
What do you think about that?
And I'm going on a little show of solidarity.
I'm sick of fucking this,
this whole new,
uh,
this new,
what do they call it?
This new climate now,
this new,
uh,
petri dish with the fuck is this new atmosphere.
And you know,
I went to one of those chemical bars the other night,
wasn't drinking and I went there and it was one of those things with a fucking,
you know,
it's like a chemistry thing.
This guy's got a paintbrush out and he's painting the inside of a glass.
Then he likes something on fire,
blows it out,
puts the smoke into the glass and then pours the drinking and everybody would
then drinks and it's like,
oh my God,
this is the love the movie.
I don't buy it.
I couldn't taste,
I mean,
my sense of taste and smell is kind of bad.
But I,
to me it just seemed like that dude on green acres,
you know,
when he would come up with some hunk of Shit and like just a rusted out radiator
and be like,
this is a gene you learn.
Uh,
but soon from Rio,
I mean,
just see which just make up shit.
This guy basically was trying to say that he takes an apple and he sucks the
atmosphere out of it.
Does he literally said that and like Colorado or I didn't know what the fuck he
was talking about and he tells you this fucking story that is so heavy on the
chemistry.
You can't help but feel like a fucking idiot.
So by the time he dips the straw in it and gives you a chance to taste it,
it's like that moment when you're in a fancy restaurant and somebody gives you a
pours a glass of wine and it's that,
that you know is you're swirling it around acting like you can taste the
difference between a $90 in a fucking $4 bottle of wine.
I can't,
I have never drank wine.
And Ben like,
yeah,
you know,
no,
now it's fucking wine.
It tastes like wine.
I don't have that sophisticated level POW.
So by the time this guy got done explaining,
sucking the atmosphere out of an apple,
it's like at this point,
it's almost like if you say it tastes like a God damn,
you know what it tasted like?
It tasted like a,
you know,
like homemade popsicles,
awful.
Or when you have a popsicle and it kind of melted a little bit and is that the
gooey shit is on the inside of the wrapper and for some reason you,
you,
you lick the wrapper.
Just how fucking gross.
So that made it tasted like that level of sweet and everybody was just taking
the straws,
just taken it and they're like,
oh my God.
And I was like,
either I'm a fucking moron or this is like the emperor's new clothes because
this shit is just,
it tastes like a popsicle.
Um,
was that story worth telling?
I don't know.
Looking back,
maybe not.
But looking forward,
um,
a buddy of mine,
standup comedian was involved in a scandal,
air quotes.
You know what he was doing?
He was in a comedy club trying out new jokes.
Can you believe that?
What the fuck was he thinking?
People d does anybody out there understand that?
You have no right to get offended when you,
when you as a,
as a,
an adult makes the free choice to go into a comedy club.
All right?
You don't have a right to be offended.
You don't,
you don't.
All right.
You just,
the second you walk in there,
everything is fucking free game.
That's what it is.
All right.
That's,
it's not like you hired a comedian to do a private party and you gave them a
list of shit of subjects that you wanted him to stay away from him or her and
that comedian agreed to it.
Now,
if that's the case,
you're paying them and said,
hey,
don't bring up a fucking cheese whiz and the person does a bit on an agrees to
not do it and then goes up there and does that exact thing then yeah,
not only do they owe you an apology,
you shouldn't even fucking pay him cause they,
they voided out the contract.
But in a comedy club,
you didn't hire those comedians.
You decided to go down there and watch comedians try out material,
give you their best shit,
give something that kind of works.
Throw some shit against the wall.
That's our house.
That's our Dojo.
You're not entitled to a fucking apology.
Um,
I thought that was the most read.
They have to have two people bitching about that.
Dan Cook joke.
It's like they don't even,
didn't even get the joke.
The joke was not making fun of the victims in Colorado.
It was using that as a,
as a,
as a reference.
He was talking about how bad he thought the new Batman movie was.
So right out of the gate,
half the people didn't even get what the fuck.
And joke was about.
And then secondly,
Dane didn't film himself and then upload that onto the Internet.
Somebody in the crowd did.
Right.
So why does he have to apologize?
He told that joke in La and they tell you at the beginning of the show,
do not videotape the comedians.
Please do not videotape the comedians and the person videotapes them.
And by the way,
I heard the crowd laugh,
joke sounded like it did all right.
Wasn't a complete joke.
It's just,
you know,
something he's working on and some of the best material comes out of that
material.
So he has to basically apologize for building a new hour of material.
You know,
I don't get that.
You don't,
and I don't think that comedian should apologize.
I think it's absolute bullshit.
And um,
look,
there's all different kinds of comedy.
Does dark comedy,
there's this absurd,
there's blue,
this squeaky clean and it's like music.
There's all different kinds of music.
Go gravitate towards the shit that you like.
But like,
you know,
if some asshole in the crowd films a comedian in a comedy club,
our house,
our Dojo and puts it up there if you've got a fucking problem with,
uh,
it being there,
talked to the person who videotaped it because I think that's the only person
that needed to apologize.
All right.
He should apologize for Dane for taking taping his act and then he should
apologize to anybody.
Uh,
you know,
I guess who fucking saw this new joke that Dane didn't put on a special or do on
fucking Letterman.
It's the stupidest fucking thing on the planet.
Go Fuck Yourself.
And you know what kills me is when you apologize,
you're actually,
I feel like that's an admission then you're saying the other person was right.
Like,
yeah,
I meant that in a malicious way.
You know?
Like what kind of a more on watch that joke and actually thought that Dane was
actually supporting what that's psycho did in Colorado.
You know what I mean?
Who,
who,
who is that fucking stupid,
you know?
Yeah.
I don't know.
And like I said,
at the end of the day he just told the joke in the comedy club and the crowd
laughed.
That's what kills me on all of these.
The crowd fucking laugh I've wrote on Twitter were to quote myself here too.
They have to have and just just have a new level of arrogance on this podcast,
you know,
after the last one.
Okay.
Was it Tasha I think was the last one is the philosophical question is if a
comedian tells a joke in a comedy club and the whole crowd laughs except for one
person.
Is it really a national news story?
You know,
cause that's another thing too is I feel like that's just like,
it's like a good way to kill five minutes on a newscast where you can just say
that there's outrage where there was no outrage,
there was no outreach,
there wasn't.
If there was like truly outrage,
you were heard it after he told the joke,
you would heard people yelling out,
groans,
moans.
You would have heard that you didn't,
you heard a [inaudible].
The joke got a decent laugh.
That was it.
And then he moved onto the next one.
It's,
I mean,
is that don't stand ups going to be,
now you're gonna have to just sit there and be like,
I'd like to apologize to anybody who is lactose intolerant.
I should have chosen my words more carefully.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Right.
Am I at,
in my mind,
I uh,
I dunno.
It's a whole new world,
whole new world of fucking snitches just out there.
Just trying to get people in trouble.
All right,
well here's something for you.
Eat voice everybody.
Would you like to have a,
would you like to have your cell phone ring but have people not know what your
real number is?
You know,
wouldn't you like to get like have a cell phone,
right?
And only your friends and family knew the real number to it.
And then you could come up with these virtual phone numbers that people could
dial the,
but weren't really your phone number,
but your cell phone would still ring.
Would you be into that?
Would you be into a service like he voice that will allow you to do that?
And off these,
these virtual phone numbers,
you could actually,
a,
you could do conference calling on your own new business and on the conference
call a feature where you could have actually up to 95 people for each extension.
It's incredible.
It's basically,
it's a business phone number that will,
that will ring on your cell phone.
Okay.
Without anybody knowing your personal one,
which gives you the option of knowing whether it's a business one or a personal
one and not answering it and whatever.
It's absolutely perfect.
It's an amazing thing.
Um,
they offer an entire service where you can,
uh,
free local managing of outgoing calls.
This is all,
all the,
uh,
this is all the,
the,
what are the options?
Can't even think this week.
Uh,
mobility all calls forwarded to a number slash people don't have to know your,
uh,
your personal phone number,
virtual numbers.
So long as you have a real number,
you can give out fake numbers,
but it rings on your own number.
And if you don't pick up on your business,
uh,
your,
your new virtual,
um,
phone number,
they actually have professional accents,
a professional,
a voice actress to give you any,
any sort of like,
like an outgoing message.
Like if you wanted to give the illusion that your business is bigger than it is,
you have a bunch of employees.
One of the options that they have is that you can actually have,
like I personally,
I would pick some sexy female voice with like a British accent.
Just gives your business credibility.
You know,
they'll send you emails with the text transcription,
the voicemail,
um,
or not.
The option is totally yours.
Uh,
it's a great way to basically have all these different business lines without
having to drill a bunch of holes in the wall in your house.
You know,
you've got ll welcome to you a widget.
Widgets are us or whatever.
I'm doing a bad accident.
You don't,
I'm saying you can start the whole frigging thing.
So it's email he voice.
Check it out today.
Do I have a website here?
Where the hell is this?
Hang on one second.
Let me get this website.
Yeah.
It's a voice.com.
There you go,
bill here,
genius.
Um,
once again,
he voices your mobile phone at work.
It's perfect for business.
A business person on the move.
Uh,
like myself,
I'm actually going to get one of these phone numbers just because when I
traveled from Club to club and all these,
uh,
different radio stations,
like my,
my phone number gets out there and,
and I,
I get weird phone calls sometimes.
You know,
I rented a car in Chicago would like Avis like three months ago and then out of
nowhere I got it.
I had to write down my fucking cell phone number.
And,
uh,
the guy worked at Eva's called me up.
No,
actually sent me a text.
Hey,
saw you stand up the other day.
Really funny.
I'm the guy who rented you the car at Avis,
which is beyond creepy and I'm a dude,
so I can only imagine how that would make a female.
So it gives you a great,
like a privacy options while you still exist in the base business world.
Um,
features eve voice offers includes call forwarding,
call routing,
toll free 800 numbers,
auto attendant,
um,
advanced voicemail,
voicemail detects or voicemail to email.
However the hell you want to do it.
A click on the voice banner on billboard.com on the podcast page or go to www
dot [inaudible] dot com slash bill burr to get your exclusive six month free
trial,
six month free trial evil.
Yeah,
he voice your mobile phone at work.
Um,
that's one of those ideas where I'm just like,
that right there is why I'm not a billionaire because I just look at that.
Like that idea was just out there and uh,
I just did nothing.
Why didn't I jump on that?
Like Youtube.
That's one of those ideas.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
and another thing real quick here,
we've got legal zoom and this is for a,
so a voice there.
There's your business phone number.
Now if you actually want to get incorporated these two right here,
he voice in legal zoom.
If you're sitting in a cubicle right now and you want to somehow get out,
if you have a business idea or an adventure or anything,
these two,
these two companies we'll get,
we'll,
we'll somehow get you out of that God damn cubicle.
All right,
here we go.
Legal Zone.
Uh,
you've probably heard about legal zoom.com.
but now I'm telling you about it,
so you got to check them out.
These guys are,
uh,
these guys are great and I wish I knew about him when I was going to get
incorporated a,
if you've been waiting for the perfect time to start your dream business,
it's right now.
Incorporate Your Business or form an LLC at legal zoom,
dark.com starting at just 99 bucks.
I paid like 1500.
I had an accountant and a lawyer and all that crap.
Cosmic 1500 bucks.
These guys start off at 99 bucks and then a whole nother level.
If you have a family and you want to protect him,
uh,
guess what?
You can protect your family and assist with the legals,
uh,
and assets with the legal zoom will for just 69 bucks.
All right?
In the past 12 years,
over 2 million Americans have used legal zoom for Llcs,
wills,
trusts,
trademarks,
and more.
They've save hundreds,
even thousands of dollars versus going to a traditional lawyer,
legal zooms online process guides,
guides you step by step,
you get total customer support.
It couldn't be much easier.
And I know what a lot of you are thinking,
well,
there's all that legal Mumbo jumbo.
What if I fill it out wrong?
Don't worry about it.
They even have attorneys that can help you out if you need a,
if you need it as you're working through all the legal legalities of it.
Um,
so anyways,
Start Your Business and protect your family today@legalzoom.com you also get a
special discount from listening to this podcast.
Make sure you enter bur bur in the referral box at checkout for more savings.
Legal Zoom is not a law firm and self help services are provided at your
direction.
There you go.
All right,
so there's that back to the podcast.
Did I read that correctly?
Do I have to apologize to anybody?
You know,
who do I have to Apollo?
Who would I have to apologize for that?
The uh,
reading out loud,
anonymous
foundation,
whatever the fuck it is.
Have you noticed that they only go after?
They only try to make really successful.
I'll apologize
because God knows I've said enough shit on this podcast.
Have an eye that at some point should and I have to issue an apology,
you know?
I don't know.
That's why I like,
I like my life is no one's dependent on me.
I go out and do stand up.
No biggie,
right?
It's just me.
I do this podcast.
If I fuck this up,
I just fucked myself over.
But either way you can't stop me from doing either one of these,
you know,
maybe it could affect the amount of listeners.
I have amount of people come out to my shows,
but I'm not motivated by money.
You know,
as you can tell by my wardrobe,
my motivation is I don't ever want to have somebody telling me what I have to
do.
You know,
a get over there and pick up that boy.
You go fucking pick it up.
You can't.
You know,
I always hated that.
I don't like having a boss.
So that was my dream in life,
not having a boss and I don't.
So you can do it yourself.
Get your fucking ass out of your cubicle.
All right.
Get yourself a virtual phone number and he voice and get yourself incorporated
or trademark your invention@legalzoom.com right there.
I gave you the tools,
you know,
I'll shut up bill.
All right,
I'll shut up.
Um,
oh,
by the way,
speaking of Dane Cook,
let's,
let's talk about some positive Dane Cook News.
Um,
Dane sent me an email.
All right,
I'm in his circle,
not bragging.
He mentioned that he was going to be at the Hollywood bowl performing in the
musical,
the producers.
And he said,
come on down if you want to.
So I was in that dilemma where I loved Dane.
But I,
I'm not a fan of musicals.
Um,
I'm just not a fan of them.
And that goes by just,
you know,
it's fucking bullshit as I went and I saw one and I actually enjoyed it,
but that's just one of those guy things you can't say that you're a fan of and
musical,
you know.
So I went down there like,
all right,
I gotta support thing so I'm gonna go to hell thing.
It was fucking hilarious.
It was at the Hollywood bowl and uh,
unbelievable performances.
And I would tell you something right now.
Dane absolutely fucking killed it.
I wish I had an nia down here cause I'm friends,
you know,
you think,
oh,
you're friends with them so you just going to say that.
No,
he fucking killed it.
And I was so proud of them and I was sitting there watching it,
remembering all these hell gigs we did like 20 years ago at like fucking this
pub.
Kelly's was the first time I think I saw Dane or maybe at this comedy club,
stitches.
I mean half the half the gigs.
I like the first 200 gigs I did.
Half of them were done in places where it wasn't a comedy club and most of the
crowd didn't even know that there was going to be a show and we'd always be in
the corner.
I remember it'd be me,
Dane,
Al Del,
Benny,
Bobby Kelly,
Patrice O'Neil,
all the guys I started and we'd just be huddling over in the corner,
just gone out of this is going to suck.
This is going to just go eat a bag of dicks.
That was like one of the first comedy expressions I learned.
This is going to suck a big bag of fucking elk dick,
and you would just sit there and watch your friend go up there and just
absolutely just humiliation.
Just standing there trying to make people laugh who aren't listening and don't
want to fucking show and just taking those fucking lumps.
And I remember Dane would just was always would go full out,
totally commit.
And when I was watching him in that show last night,
I was seeing all these little,
little subtle things that I used to see him doing all his hotel rooms than it
was fucking great.
And I said,
what's up to him in the end?
And when I walked out,
it was hilarious.
Was One of the leads in it,
is that red headed dude with the,
with the beard on modern family.
The guy was hilarious and he was,
he was great in this musical too.
And uh,
when I walked out it was fucking hilarious.
I see this guy look kind of tilts his head to the side.
He got excited looking at me as I'm walking out and then his face dropped and I
was like,
you know,
my ego,
I'm thinking,
oh,
he recognizes me as a comedian and uh,
I can't confirm this,
but I think he thought I was that dude
from a distance.
He thought I was that guy on modern family.
And then when he saw me and my hairline,
he's like,
oh,
that's,
that's not him.
That's just some jackass with a beard.
Um,
oh,
it wasn't that sad.
Hey,
I got a drum question for Y'alls,
uh,
for the drummers.
Any drummers who listened to this?
Um,
I can't decide on this one.
That song by Van Halen main streets.
Does Alex play that?
The high hat?
Does he play it with two hands or with one?
I saw him live in concert.
He played it with two and then I watched the video the other day and he played
it with one.
Uh,
but he wasn't playing straight sixteenths.
But when I listened to it on the album,
it sounds like it's straight sixteenths cause somebody please help me with that
because I'm working,
working,
getting back to the,
the push pull thing with the stick,
trying to get it up to speed.
And how do you do that?
Why listen to Lenny Kravitz?
Uh,
it ain't over till it's over.
And then I listened to what's his face?
Uh,
uh,
Bill withers use me and I just keep,
I play up to temple with each hand and each day can play a little bit longer,
but I pay attention to the fact I don't want my forearms burning because if they
are,
then I'm not doing it right.
You know,
for years that you aren't,
aren't drummers,
one of the things your problem you have is uh,
you know,
if you have great technique,
you can effortlessly play the drums and you don't have to deal with carpal
tunnel or any fucking injuries or any of that shit.
So sorry,
that was my own little thing.
And speaking to that,
I want to start,
I want to start making some drum covers and upload them onto youtube
anonymously.
You guys will never find them,
so good luck to you.
But I,
I'm using that I movie 2012 and I don't obviously know,
can film myself and upload myself,
but I don't know how to,
how do you drop the music in?
You know what I mean?
So you hear my drums,
plane,
you know,
it's like I shoot the video and all you hear is me playing the drums to whatever
song.
Right?
And then what I want to do is drop in the audio of the song and like obviously
have an instinct to me playing the drums because I just want to see what kind of
reviews and when to get,
cause if I put it up there and it's me,
first of all,
it's going to look cheesy and then second of all it's going to be,
I dunno,
I want people looking at,
I want people watching it.
Like this guy actually wants to try and make it as a drummer because I want
honest criticism.
And then I will,
I'm not going to tell you where they are on Youtube,
but I will read you the worst comments.
How about that?
Is that fair?
That'll be good for some comedy.
All right.
Okay.
Here we go.
Response to Penn state should keep their wins.
Last week I talked about,
uh,
you know,
obviously I agreed with every,
every punishment that came down on Penn state except for the,
uh,
I just thought them losing their victories.
I just felt like that punish the players and the fans and the fans and the
players were 100% innocent.
And this guys who's NFL dreams died because they blew out their knee in a game
that they won and now you're going to take that away from them.
And I just feel like,
uh,
it just seemed like it went above and beyond.
So this guy says,
Bill,
in response to your,
your view that Penn state shouldn't have to forfeit the winds.
Should Germany have been allowed to keep the countries they conquered in World
War II?
No.
I like when people ask me a question like,
and I think that they want my opinion,
but they just answer it themselves.
So he says no,
when we kicked their fucking axe ass is we took away their land,
took away their army and place sanctions on them.
We didn't say,
hey,
Hitler's dead.
So why should we punish the rest of you?
Germans,
we made a fucking example out of them and we need to do to do the same thing to
Penn state.
Not all the Germans were Nazis.
Not all the players did anything wrong.
Did anything wrong,
dude?
None of the players did anything wrong.
What fucking,
what Internet do you have?
What,
what TV shows are you watching?
Um,
if they have a problem,
go immigrate to another university where wins.
Count enough with the poor me.
Bullshit.
Your Supreme Holier Than Thou ruler fucked up big time.
Fuck him and all you queer lions.
So there you go.
You know what sir?
You were starting to make a point there and then in the end,
you,
you end up,
you know that that's like a typical inner internet point.
You start to make a point and then you either say something racist or homophobic
in the end.
Uh,
first of all,
I disagree with that analogy.
Um,
because that analogy,
you're suggesting that the Penn state players were Joe Paterno was army and that
they were in the know and Joe Paternal was Hitler and the people in the army
were,
they knew what the fuck he was doing and they helped him.
They helped him do it,
which they didn't.
They didn't.
They would just playing football games.
All right.
And,
uh,
should Germany had been allowed to keep the countries they conquered in World
War II?
Well,
I wore is like a game dude.
That's a game.
All right.
And they won the first half and they lost the game.
So no,
they shouldn't be.
But uh,
they did conquer France and that is in the history books.
They fought France and world war two and they beat them.
That victory counts.
They conquered Poland,
they conquered the fucking Netherlands.
They lost in England.
They lost to the Russians and they lost to us.
So right there,
off the top of my head,
they were three and three.
They conquered a Norway with the help of Sweden.
Right.
All,
all those wins and losses count,
sir.
So I don't know what you're saying.
Like that point doesn't make any sense.
And the fact that the NSC,
you're all,
uh,
all,
you know,
fuck him and you're queer lions,
that basically sounds to me like you're a fan of a team in the big 10,
or maybe you like one of them southern coaches that had,
you know,
more wins than Joe Pos.
So,
uh,
I agree to disagree,
sir.
And,
um,
you lose points on your,
your hacky example of Germany and the Nazis.
It always comes down to that no matter you do,
I pick up my dog shit and I throw it in somebody else's trashcan and they go,
could you please
it's trash.
You worried that I'm going to make your trash thank you know.
And then they'll say something.
Well,
did hint when Hitler,
it isn't,
it isn't like when Hitler,
it isn't.
Okay.
You should have gone like John Wayne Gacy there.
That's what I would have gone anyways.
All right.
Female roommate.
How to bill.
You said howdy some reading all of this and a southern accent.
I could use some advice,
uh,
out of 27 year old Guy Leonean and apartment.
And Eh,
with a 19 year old girl.
She did Lou in a couple weeks ago,
a couple months ago.
Uh,
we've been getting along great.
But over the past few weeks she's mentioned her sex life a couple of different
times.
Mentioned how she loves to give head.
Could it be the most perfect rule made in the world?
Uh,
you're the reason that God made a Ho.
All right,
so she likes suck and Dick.
Okay,
I see nothing but sunshine so far.
Where,
where,
where's the rain coming?
Here we go.
And just the other day she mentioned out of the blue that she posed for some
nude pictures.
Oh.
And she has no problem with nudity.
All right.
That's a major caution flag there.
Anybody who takes nude photos or is in the,
uh,
the porn industry.
Yeah.
You got to watch out there.
That's a ticking time bomb.
Oh Gee.
She's what happened and was it your uncle?
Was it the guy down the street?
Who Was it?
Uh,
she seems to basically say everything she thinks.
Uh Oh.
She basically said,
it seems to say everything that she thinks will get a rise out of me.
Rise.
You get it.
That's what he said.
He put that in parentheses.
All right,
here we go.
At first I didn't know how to approach the situation,
so I just ignored her when she tried to steer the conversation towards sex,
but she seemed to do this repeatedly and I had enough with it and I came onto
her and told her that I wanted to see the pictures and then joke with her that
it was for artistic reasons.
Um,
she seemed shocked that I'd asked such a question.
Oh,
here she goes,
going to yank the rug out.
And she joked with me and called me a creeper.
She seemed to flaunt her sexuality in front of me and say,
I'll open.
She is with everything.
But the second I made a move,
she made me feel like a creek.
There you go.
You got one of those,
sir.
uh,
gee.
Oh Gee,
she's,
this is the,
this is like,
she's a,
an Olympic level.
Uh,
uh,
what do you call Dick Tease and I say Olympic level cause she's actually dabbled
in the porn industry with the nude photos.
Um,
I either want to bang this girl or get her to quit throwing her sexual
suggestive topics at me and quit using me as an emotional tampon.
Helped me out,
Bill.
Go Fuck Yourself.
I would say exactly what you just said.
That the bang part.
Just say listen.
MMM.
Just,
you know,
you don't want you to,
you just go,
I would just go fucking
okay.
Don't curse.
Don't say anything fucked up.
Just straight out.
Say,
just say,
listen.
Ever since you've been here,
you have been just openly talking about sex.
You talk about how you enjoy giving oral sex.
You mentioned that you have nude photos,
you don't have a problem with nudity,
you're constantly bringing up sex.
Okay.
And the other day,
you know,
no,
I can't go that way.
Cause then she'll be like,
well cause you came up like a creep.
Just tell her,
look,
don't,
don't bring up sex anymore.
Can you pull,
just don't,
don't bring up sex anymore.
Uh,
and just when she says,
why just say,
cause I'm not comfortable with you talking about it.
All right.
I would just like to have a roommate to roommate relationship.
You know,
I'm not trying to be a jerk.
I just please don't talk about sex anymore and that would be perfect because
then you will totally like take away all of her powers.
So you just took the rope away from wonder woman right there.
Yeah.
I want you to take a rope off.
She can't find her jet.
Isn't that how it worked?
C'Mon nerds.
Any nerds listening to this and actually it's not true.
She could see her invisible jet.
That was one of the dumbest thing that was such like a shelf in a stick thing
that they gave her,
wasn't it?
An invisible jet.
Superman can fly by himself,
doesn't even need,
doesn't even need a fucking plane.
Wonder woman can't fly.
She needs a jet just like the rest of ours.
But to make it an interesting,
they make it invisible.
Not at any point did they say that wonder woman invented the invisible jet?
You know,
she didn't.
She didn't.
She's too busy fucking going to the gym,
you know,
keeping her stomach flat and fucking around with that rope.
So that's all she really is.
She's just kinda like this.
Uh,
well I guess she can block bullets with the wristbands,
so that's unbelievably like reptilian quickness.
So I'll give her that.
But other than that,
you know,
if she wants to go to California,
she's got to get on a plane just like the rest of us.
And she's got a fly yourself out,
which I guess is kind of cool.
I don't know how hot was fucking,
was it that was going to say Linda Blair was Linda Evans to fuck was her name.
Claire,
what was the name of the woman who played a wonder woman
in,
in the late seventies Oh,
did I love her?
I've loved every fucking,
that's back before there was like 9,000 channels.
So every woman on television back then,
you know,
if they were playing a sexy role,
it wasn't,
they weren't outside the box,
no pun intended.
They would just fucking straight up.
They were a 10.
She was hot.
All three Charlie's angels.
They were all hot.
Jamie Summers,
the bionic woman,
she was fucking hot.
MMM.
Three's company.
I thought they were both hot.
I liked them all.
Alice was hot.
Vera was hot in a weird way.
You could keep flow.
That'd be one once in a while,
but they were all,
they were all like,
they will hot Gloria.
You know,
if you get past her voice,
she was a fucking hottie.
Been somebody ugly.
I really wasn't.
Marsha was hot.
Jan,
by the end of it,
she came into her own.
Yeah,
just a bunch of Hardees.
Hardees they weren't hoary though.
They didn't have horseback then.
You know?
Did they?
I don't know.
All right,
let's plow ahead here.
Depressed dude.
A Billy cont exclamation point.
I've been listening.
I've been listening to your podcast for years.
You're derange psychopathic perspective reminds me,
I'm not the only one.
Shake and ladders.
I don't know what that means is this guy from Boston.
I've been listening to the podcast for years.
You drained psychopathic perspective reminds me,
I'm not the only one shake in lad his kid.
That still is a song.
Even if the accident shaken ladders.
I know what that means.
Anyways.
I got a problem.
Yeah,
I was in Boston all last week.
So the basketball,
the Boston accent kind of came back the whole,
uh,
you know,
I got a problem.
Uh,
get a job and get a Julep.
Dodi's you get a job.
And for those of you working on your Boston accents job,
just say like jaw.
Like I'm going to punch you in the jaw.
And then B job.
Got To get a fucking job.
You know,
kills me right now.
He's like fucking 200.
You right now.
Just muttering to yourself,
get a fucking job and your cubicle.
I'm freaking out.
Your coworkers,
just mumbling.
Get a fucking job.
You fucking Cock sucker.
Um,
I got a problem for years now.
I've been trapped in my KFC and wet wipes.
Okay,
that's disgusting.
I used to be a bodybuilder and actor and a comedian with fucking prospects right
in front of me,
but then adulthood raped me in the eyes.
Oh,
Jesus.
Could you be more dramatic?
It sounds like that fucking chick from
sex in the city,
uh,
crazy.
Broke my hat.
I had,
this is the guy again,
crazy,
broad,
broke my heart.
I had to cut away old friends and family shutting me out of their smiles.
All right,
so this is like getting creepier with each sentence.
If you don't bring this around in like two sentences,
I'm going to abandon this.
Had to cut away from old friends and family shutting me out of their smiles.
Dude,
what did you do that your friends and family decided they didn't want to be
around you?
Uh,
anyways,
I don't feel sorry for myself for one.
Any pity you're not going to get any.
So good.
I'm glad you don't.
He goes,
I just want to know how to get out of this.
Never ending routine of demise.
Well,
first of all,
I would stop using those goth death metal words,
you know,
demise.
What else you got in here?
Adult rape me in the eyes.
These he like song lyrics,
you know,
depress dude.
What would be the name of his is trapped and Barker.
I'm sure you're going to wipe wipes,
right?
It sounds like I can't sing like that,
Where do you all like dish?
We'll key it up to my eyes and all these fucking kids getting like wet fucking
whiplash.
Um,
I worked too much in a jeweler that was supposed to pay for my comedy career.
When I don't work,
I,
uh,
I was suppose to pay for my comedy career when I,
when I don't work,
uh,
I sleep or oh,
when I don't work,
I sleep or watch endless DVDs.
I'm 24 years old of what the fuck this reads.
Like.
You're 56,
dude.
He goes,
I'm tired all the time from all the hating of the world and my body just won't
listen to the screaming frustration in my soul.
Dude,
you listened to light.
You listen to progressive metal.
I'm guessing by the words you use here,
uh,
either that you played dungeons and dragons.
I'm really not helping you to depression by shitting on you through all of this.
Um,
don't worry.
I'm going to give you some sunshine here in the end here.
It's,
I sometimes get a Spock,
a motivation to get back in shape and,
and start writing script,
but only lasts for a day or two at the most.
Yeah,
exactly.
And then,
and then the work comes and you have to keep going.
And that's what separates the people in life who fucking work and in make it.
And those who don't,
you know,
everything's fun for a couple of fucking days.
I'm going to get shredded.
I'm going to join a boxing gym.
I'm going to look like I'm going to fight in a title fight and you go down
there,
you skip rope.
I'm going to get abs.
You doing all the fucking shit in two days in,
you know,
after two days you,
you get tired.
All right?
And that's what you need the discipline to get up and go over there.
Even though you don't want to,
you know,
people who've written Oscar winning scripts.
I bet they don't like fucking doing it on,
on a certain level,
but they keep going.
So I would just tell you to keep fucking going.
Anyways,
let me read the rest of this drum overly dramatic shit.
I've lost all faith in the world.
Have nothing to fight for anymore.
I respect you.
Go Fuck yourself attitude and want and want to know what you did to finally pick
yourself up from your Darfur inflicted depression.
Uh,
sorry,
it's not the funniest emails,
but I could really do with you guys.
I know,
dude,
I'm fucking with you.
I know you're going through some shit.
So I,
here we go.
I'm going to help you out here.
Uh,
first thing I would do,
get rid of the KFC in wet wipes.
All right?
If you're already kind of a depressed dude,
if you eat bad food,
that's just going to add because I'm just speaking personally.
Once again,
not a licensed guy here in case you throw yourself off the fucking roof.
All right?
Um,
yeah.
Number one,
this is what I do.
Go.
He'd go out and get something healthy to eat,
you know,
drink some water.
Okay?
Get eight hours sleep,
wake up and eat something healthy.
Then go to the grocery store when you full and go buy a bunch of healthy shit.
Okay.
Chop up the veggies,
chop up the lettuce,
get a fucking salad already made in there so you don't have to think about it.
All right?
Cook up some fucking chicken.
Chop that shit up.
Make some chicken salad.
You got that in there to get yourself some fucking lunch breed and get yourself
some real bread from a fucking bakery.
Start with that bullshit.
You start eating right and then just start working out.
You're automatically gonna feel good about yourself and fucking stick with that
as far as that other shit goes.
Dude,
you're 24 years old.
All right.
I started comedy when I was 24 you sound like you've already been doing it and
quit,
so you're ahead of where,
where I was at at your age,
so there's no reason to be depressed.
All right.
Um,
this is how I got beyond my depression was I just started observing it.
I looked at it as a spectator rather than feeling a thought and just accepting
it and then being dragged to the bottom of the fucking ocean with it.
I just started to pay attention.
I just sat there and listened to what my brain was telling me and it was a bunch
of negative,
oh my God,
I'm gonna fail and I have to go back,
move in with my parents and they're going to die.
I'm going to be able to afford to pay for the house and then I'm going to be
homeless and then I'm just going to die.
And uh,
you know,
nothing's ever going to work out for me.
You know?
Those were the thoughts I was having.
So I just sat back and observed him and I just started going,
I don't want to think that.
I want to think that.
And I would just,
as I felt him coming,
I would just replace it with like a positive thought.
I know this is really corny and simple,
but I kind of started doing that.
And the more I did that because it didn't quite work as to what actually didn't
work in the beginning at all.
But like I just kept doing it more and more and then I just became conscious of
when my brain was going in that direction and I'm working out.
Helps me eating right.
Helps me going down to a comedy club,
telling jokes helps me out playing drums,
wrestling with my dog,
you know,
take Nia out to dinner.
Just go do something.
Like it's just a choice.
July 30th so only going to happen once.
So am I going to fucking be a miserable can't on this or I said July 30th,
2012 is only gonna happen unless it's just,
it's just a fucking choice dude.
So,
you know,
if what you deal with his clinical,
then it's obviously way beyond me,
so I don't need,
you know,
and then I'll like to fucking apologize like Fred Willard.
Um,
I'm sorry that you didn't go to a psychiatrist and you went to a hacky comedian
instead.
Evidently that's my fault.
All right,
plowing ahead.
Um,
what are we up to here with time?
Gigi,
she's flied by um,
girl found porn
boy meets girl,
girl finds porn.
Boy is embarrassed.
That's what I'm guessing.
All right.
A few years.
A few years ago I was in a relationship and one morning my girl went snooping
around on my computer when I was in the shower in a classic rookie mistake.
I did not delete any of the porn sites I had visited from my history.
I'm not an internet porn addict or anything,
but I am a dude and not only do I enjoy the occasional fucking Schwab session,
whatever that means,
I guess jerking off,
but a lifetime of bountiful internet porn.
It has made my ability to perform the mental beat a thing of the past.
I don't know what that is.
What is the mental beat?
My ability to perform the mental beat a thing of the past.
Oh,
jerking off with just your thoughts.
Basically,
I need moving pictures.
I know many men understand my plight.
Yeah,
dude,
you got to go back to that.
Go back to the mental fucking one yet.
Oh,
it's a lot cheaper.
Nobody knows what you thinking about.
It's a safe world.
Um,
anyway,
she was all kinds of pissed off.
Asked me why.
I was looking at a site called youporn while starting to cry.
She was a seventh degree black belt at the guilty crying style of fighting,
meaning when she wants an instant victory,
she cries and I cave.
So I played the only card I could defeat,
I could to diffuse the situation,
which was to lie.
I said that a buddy sent me an email link to that site because he thought he saw
someone from our high school on there.
She immediately came back with,
but it's in the top 10 of your most viewed sites on your history.
Ah,
Jeez.
I got to give it up to her right there,
man.
She went fucking Colombel on you and you walked right into the,
so he goes,
at this point,
I just came clean and told her that all the dude's still catch a beat.
That all dudes catch a beat even when they're in a relationship.
And it doesn't mean that we don't find her girlfriends desirable.
I tried to make it funny and said I was training my Hogan to gain Stan Umma
stamina.
So really she should be more encouraging.
That's actually funny.
Alas,
she wanted none of it and was in total shock that I was doing this.
She said that none of her previous boyfriends ever looked at porn,
let alone rub one out well in a relationship.
Okay.
What fantasy planet the she live on.
Um,
he goes to them,
became pissed that she would be so naive to think that that was true and told
her that all dudes do this and stood strong that I did nothing wrong.
She kept go,
good for you.
Standing your ground.
Good for you.
She kept coming at me with yelling,
hitting and crying.
But I remain unwavering in my stance and did not apologize.
Looking back,
I think I only took this stance because I was starting to have my doubts in
regards to the relationship and just didn't give a fuck anymore.
What do I gotta be honest with you?
Whether you gave a fuck or didn't give a fuck about her anymore,
if you totally loved somebody,
that doesn't mean you cave in 100% of the time.
You know Cavan when you're wrong,
you're right.
Sorry.
Definitely do that shit.
But like,
um,
you know,
if you can't watch porn and rub one out,
then I mean,
I don't understand like,
uh,
I mean it's,
it's a slippery slope starts with that.
And the next thing you know,
you can't watch the game.
Right?
I don't fucking know.
Anyways.
Um,
it turns out we broke up a few weeks later and you better believe she threw this
incident back in my face when she was having the goat getting killed by a python
last struggle that you had previously made analogies about.
Anyways,
I have a new girlfriend now,
which I like more,
but I was wondering how I would handle the situation with someone I really love.
So what do you think the best way to handle this situation if it happened to you
or any other guy?
Um,
you know,
I don't think it's a big deal if you're not watching it habitually.
If he occasionally watch it,
some women consider it cheating.
Um,
I don't know how the fuck do I hit?
Well,
I'm lucky knee doesn't give a shit.
She doesn't care.
She would care if I hadn't done anything with her for awhile.
And I was doing that I,
that would bother her.
But like she doesn't give a shit what I do.
Um,
I think someone has to accept you for who you are.
All right and let in.
Unless you're like,
you know,
if you occasionally smoke weed,
casually have a drink,
occasionally watched porn who gives a fuck.
But if you're always smoking weed,
if you're a fucking alcoholic or you,
you're,
you,
uh,
addicted to porn,
then I think that,
um,
there's a problem.
But,
uh,
I would just do what you do,
you know,
if you think it's an issue and you need to bring it up,
I would just bring it up and say,
listen,
what am I just to let you know,
I occasionally rub one out to porn and I'm,
my one girlfriend really had a fucking problem with it.
And before we go any further,
I just want to make sure you don't,
so there's no weird arguments.
I can't lie to you.
That's not exactly an easy thing to bring up.
Uh,
which is why you just kind of have to be yourself in a relationship.
So then it won't come out of left field because if you're being overly polite,
overly jolly,
overly,
you know,
just accentuating the good parts about you and not showing your seedier side,
uh,
that really is going to come out of left field.
So,
um,
does that make any sense?
I would definitely,
I'd bring it up.
You know,
so sweetie,
are we going to dinner tonight by the way?
And you like porn cause I do,
I rub one out every once in a while to chicks do it.
Really know where are you going?
Oh my fucking ear is killing me.
Do you know my dog cause my ear to bleed?
She gave my fucking ear ahead bud.
If you ever get a pit bull,
you gotta watch out for the heads because they're like little wrecking balls and
um,
you know,
I hadn't been home in like a week.
I was out in Boston in the fucking north end all week.
Um,
by the way,
underrated the north end pizzeria.
Regina,
that one seat at the bar that faces the wall,
they call it their timeout chair.
You can walk right in.
You don't have to stand in line if you by yourself and just ask if you can go
sit there and at granted you have to face the wall,
why everyone at the bar shoots the shit.
But if you're a loner like myself,
it's fucking great and it's tremendous pizza.
Um,
anyway,
so I hadn't been home in like a week.
So,
uh,
you know,
my dog gets fucking excited to see me.
I'm excited to see her.
Nia let out the front,
she's fucking jumping up and down.
It come through the gate and I had a bunch of stuff in my hand and I kind of,
you know,
it was bent down to like,
Hey,
what's up?
And the dog jumped up and was like going to lick my face and basically had its
mouth kind of open and we went teeth to teeth to that point where it was like,
did I just knock out some teeth?
They definitely feel numb.
Fortunately she didn't.
So that's what happened.
Now you would think if,
if you were a smart person,
you bring your bags in the house where you had your hands free and I could calm
my dog down.
But I'm so fucking excited to see her and I get excited when she gets excited
and Ma,
you know,
I'm loving that she's,
it's fucking great when you come home and there's one person like this fucking
guy's home.
This is awesome.
Right?
So I bent down to pet her and I was,
you know,
scratching or,
or ribs and she was looking down at a tail and then she swung her head back and
I got my fucking mouth out of the way just the last second.
So he didn't knock my teeth out in the side of the head,
slammed into the side of mine and basically Mush my year.
I feel like I got suckered right in this side of the fucking ear and a fucking
bled out.
I think my ear died.
So now I got this fucking scab.
It looks like I've got this big,
what's a dirt on the side of my fucking ear for my God damn dog.
So I got the headphones on.
It hurts.
That's why I told that story as this podcast gone off the fucking rails.
Is it me?
Um,
all right.
Couple of [inaudible] to a quick ads here.
And of course I can't go back.
Why does it do this to me?
Why do you do this to me?
Can anybody explain why on these new fucking
Mac book pros,
does anybody else have this problem?
You go on the fucking Internet and when you go to go to a new window,
you open a new tab.
It won't let you go back to the other window,
even though you can click on it.
I Dunno.
Any nerds out there and know what the fuck that's about?
All right,
here we go.
Let's go real quick.
Um,
amazon.com you guys know the deal.
If you're going to buy something on Amazon,
not saying you gotta go to Bill bird.com.
Click on the podcast page and click on the banner ad on the right hand side of
the Amazon banner ad on the right hand side.
You go to Amazon,
go ahead and buy something.
It doesn't cost you any extra money.
They kicked me a percentage.
10% of that I give to the wounded warriors project.
He helped support my podcast and a the troops who made an unbelievable sacrifice
for us.
All right?
And gamefly.com what'd you love to have?
8,000 get video games at your fingertips.
Share we all what?
Um,
all the new hits mailed to your home.
So if you're sick of paying $65 for the newest games that you or your kids used
for a week,
and then give,
then give gamefly is shot game flyers offering my listeners a free two disk,
15 day trial,
$23 value.
Go to www.game fly.com or the game fly banner on the,
on my podcast page of website to redeem the offer.
They go enough with the advertising for this week back to the shoe.
All right,
my girls lost her mind.
Well,
by the way,
everybody,
that was really embarrassing last week when I thought that,
that,
that woman who wanted to hike was actually a dude.
You know,
I don't know what I was thinking.
I always just get emails from guys,
even when she said,
uh,
no one wants that ghetto pussy.
I just thought that that was just some girl like trying to be tough and talking
to a guy like he was a bitch.
I completely missed it and it was embarrassing.
I got 50 emails last week to said good podcasts and the other 48 w were
ridiculing me for not realizing that.
So there you go.
Alright,
last couple here and then I got to get the fuck out.
He all right.
My girls lost her mind.
What's up bill bowl?
I'm 25 and a few months ago I met a girl that blew my fucking mind.
She was smart,
creative,
beautiful,
sexy.
It had been over a year since the last girl I really cared about dumped me
because she had a religious epiphany and thought I was destroying her
relationship with Christ [inaudible] and I was beginning to think that I'd never
have that gut feeling of love for a girl again.
But this new girl,
but this new girl and oh,
but I met this new girl and I started dating and things went real fast.
Within two weeks we were together daily and things were great,
but about a month in,
I began to realize that she had a horrible temper.
Oh man,
that's brutal.
All right.
Even worse,
she tended to put words in my mouth when she'd get angry and get more mad at
things.
I didn't even fucking say.
Here's an example.
All right.
This conversation goes her,
him,
her,
him.
All right.
I'm not going to say I'm not going to,
all right,
I'll just do the voices.
Okay.
Here's his example.
Honey.
What time is the movie?
Eight 30.
I looked yesterday and I'm pretty sure it was a no,
I just looked it up.
It's eight 30.
Ah,
some stupid.
What?
No,
I didn't.
Oh,
I'm stupid.
Animal Life.
Jesus.
You don't even worse than her relationship was that acting?
Um,
I lost faith in it halfway through and it's gotten even extremely worse for the
fourth day in a row.
She's blown up at me to the point of telling me that we should just break up.
I get pissed and I'm like,
fine.
And she's like,
how dare you break up with me?
How could you do that yet?
Do this check is out of her fucking mind.
All right.
She's afraid you're going to break up with her and she's just fucking,
she's fucking,
she's sabotaging the relationship and guess what?
That's not your fucking problem.
All right?
She can go work,
workout or anger with somebody else.
Go find someone else.
You still young right now.
He's still young.
As long as you're not like over 38 there's no reason to try and wait around for
this girl to fucking get her shit together.
Anyways,
she's completely in another world.
And last night she told me the other reason why I was with her was because it
was for easy sex.
Fucking ridiculous.
She texted me to apologize.
Ended up,
oh,
she texted you to apologize,
but it ended up she started the shit all over again.
When I asked her why she even fucking say something like that to begin with
because she's out of her mine.
All right.
This is your call,
sir.
You can either date someone who is healthy and is ready to accept you and all
the wonderful things you'll bring to the table,
um,
or she can go fuck herself.
Right?
What?
I'm sorry.
Did that make any fucking sense at that?
Didn't,
did I just say that right?
I'm sorry.
I closed the window and then couldn't figure out what the hell it was.
Um,
yeah,
it's all up to you.
Do you want to deal with this bitch?
I don't think you'd do this.
Plenty of the great girls out there,
plenty of phenomenal women that'll be excited to be with you and not be a
complete psycho.
Or he could sit with this girl and maybe she'll figure this shit out.
I Dunno.
You know what I love about mia is she's not an angry person.
Okay?
Who wants to have kids with someone who isn't,
who's fucking angry?
Oh,
Jesus.
I'm glad she didn't hear that.
She fucking dumped me in a second,
you know?
But I think an angry dad is acceptable.
That's actually understandable because guys are idiots.
But if the mom's angry too,
I just can't imagine that.
I don't think that's good for kids.
Neither is an angry dead,
I guess.
Angry,
generous on a good thing.
Well,
you know,
let's look at that.
I actually learned something.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
here's,
here's some standup dates I have coming up.
Uh,
I'll be at the Improv in Orlando,
Florida September 7th through the ninth,
and I'll be at Caroline's the rescheduled date September 20th through the 23rd.
I apologize to everybody.
I had to cancel last second,
the,
uh,
the Carolina state at the end of July and moved to September 20th through 23rd.
I got that acting gig.
Uh,
I can't really tell you what it is because you never know.
You never know.
You can have a giant roll and then they go a different direction and by the time
had done editing,
you're not even in the fucking thing.
But,
uh,
I got a good feel that I'm going to be,
um,
but we shall see.
We shall see all Billy,
the actress coming around coming around and done a couple of two,
three things this year.
Uh,
speaking of which,
my favorite show,
breaking bad next week,
you guys might want to tune in.
You might want to tune in next week cause they're always great episodes.
Wink,
wink,
especially when a certain somebody wink wink might be making an appearance.
Hey,
you know what?
I saw a picture of one of the most beautiful trucks I've ever fucking seen in my
life life.
Um,
I think I've completely abandoned.
I still love cars,
but I am a total truck guy now.
And specifically I am a Ford truck guy
from literally the forties,
right through like 1968.
Those are my favorite ones.
I don't like the interiors on the 1970s for trucks.
I do,
I do love the,
the front end,
sir.
MMM.
But this guy has got a 1968.
Okay.
Uh,
the same year as mine.
F 100 with the long bed,
four wheel drive.
And it is absolutely fucking gorgeous and a,
if anybody else's into trucks,
I'm going to have that up on the,
uh,
the Amman podcast page.
Anyways,
that's the podcast for this week.
Um,
I hope this week can go by without me seeing somebody,
uh,
you know,
that I'm a fan of or even not a fan of having to apologize for not fucking doing
anything,
anything wrong.
And I'm really sick of just a lazy journalism.
Why you try to say that there's outrage when there was no outrage.
You know what I mean?
The joke basically worked.
People laughed.
It's just really fucking annoying.
So anyways,
um,
that is it.
And by the way,
if you ever see that Dane is performing in any sort of Broadway thing,
uh,
I can't recommend them highly enough.
I was absolutely fucking,
he blew me away.
And I've known this guy for 20 fucking years.
I've seen it.
I've seen all the tricks in his fucking trick bag there.
And uh,
absolutely fucking blew me away and I'm really happy for him,
especially after that fucking bullshit,
that fucking nerve filming them.
That just really ruined my fucking week when that she don't need it actually
called me up when that happened.
And like with like this concern tone going,
I know you've worked so hard.
What if something you say,
I mean that's the climate that's starting to be created,
which is the reason why people can't apologize for this shit.
I mean,
I dunno.
I guess if you're on a TV show that they get pressured to do it.
It's all bullshit that they gave me.
Like the Po apology isn't sincere.
It has to do with money.
Like all right,
well we,
we don't want people protesting this and making the show go away.
There's hundreds of people who lose their jobs.
Just fucking apologize.
I think that's why they always go after comedians who have like TV shows or have
some sort of notoriety.
If you notice that shit,
they don't go after a guy like me.
What are they going to do?
Okay.
You can't stop me from telling jokes next to a cheesecake factory in a mall.
All right?
You could maybe turn it from a three quarter full room.
Do I have full room?
But I don't give a fuck.
All right.
Ah,
that just fucking frustrating.
All right,
that's it.
Go fuck yourselves.
I'll talk to you next week.